sometimes you know Junia I don't
recognize our country anymore it's
filled with islamists parading around
the streets praising terrorists my
fellow islamists hello and myself also
Islam do you want to speak with
confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad Arad
Muhammad Arad has helped develop allot
of us it's extremely beneficial to do
this course definitely recommend this
course to access the free lifechanging
training now asalam Alum brothers and
sisters and dear friends we have got a
content for you guys we're going to
react to which you are going to be
amazed with flabbergast it's going to
bring Corners to your eyes a Content a
Content many contents is of Douglas
Murray Douglas ah I like what you did
there dogas who when the event got
cancelled he was in a bit of a hurry but
I told him don't
worry okay do you want to watch
it so so they were doing an event for I
think the these reservists that so
they've been reserved to get liquidated
okay so Israeli soldiers yeah Israeli
soldiers yes so we're not sure if it's
in this country or Israel who cares but
apparently they had to go join the Army
and the so he's raising money for
extremists yeah so the education was
affected apparently so they have to go
to join the Army so they have to raise
funds for them because right now they
left their a to go and uh commit a
genocide yeah if they're not committing
a genocide then they're on Tik Tok
videos dancing exactly not very well so
if they really educated theirself about
history they would not be committing a
genocide so maybe they should go back to
education rather than genocide agreed
now let's watch what he had to say and
let's see how he had the Meltdown the EV
was me to goad at the
AP sold out and it was as you say to
raise funds for students in isra
University many of whom have been called
up in war time and education has been
completely disrupted and uh so yes it
was a conversation uh that I was being
interviewed by the actress Lisa Klein
said apparently they felt unsafe about
the event uh then something very
Sinister occurred uh the CEO of nightx
uh who is herself Jewish um started to
get scared it seems she called in staff
from another theater one of her own
staff leaked the emails of the people
who were going to work as ushers and so
on on the evening and then they
themselves dropped out from Fear uh by
this time they how they did they
actually receive threatening them if
they to me it's interesting nowadays
know in our country seems even the
threat of a threat is enough to make
people cancel an event uh and I for any
r at any rate don't respect that at all
my view if if a Thea receives threats
about an event that's ongoing there's
one thing they do which is they call the
metropolitan police and they say your
job is to protect this venue and make
sure that it the even passes off safely
uh but they didn't do that they just as
cards as they are um cancel the event
absolutely outrageous sometimes you know
jul I don't recognize our country
anymore
f with islamists the street praising
terrorists my fellow islamists hello and
myself also islamist are we calling for
Jihad okay so what do you make of that
cuz it to me it's just like just amazing
the double standards this this um
entitlement it's unbelievable I mean
just imagine for a second that we as
Muslims hire a theater to raise funds to
a specific extremist organization
that's well accepted by the planet for
being an occupier there's an
international court that accepts
genocide to some degree taking place so
that term can't be taken off the table
this guy comes on national television
and says oh people are getting scared
because they don't want to do this event
well people whose families have been
occupied people that have been carpet
bombed people babies babies women
children you know their relatives are
clearly going to be upset but no just
imagine that for a second that this is
happening by a Muslim government or a
body or whatever you want to call it a
group towards Jewish people or the
Christians or atheist for that matter
and imagine in London I hold an event
and I rent a f I say we are going to
raise funds for these reservists who had
to go and join this Army on its genocide
there would have been sanctions on that
country bro forget sanction bro just
imagine for a second and then I came and
said yeah but it's my freedom of speech
or or it's you know the freedom for me
to do this event or whatever BR do you
really think this bastard here is going
to say yeah Ali we defend your right to
freedom of speech never look at the
double standards and hypocrisy if I was
to do such a thing they talk about
freedom of speech freedom of speech when
it suits you when you are insulting
Islam burning the Quran is freedom of
speech if I was to hire that event and
said I'm going to do an event talking
about why I believe the Holocaust never
happened do you think do you think this
scum dirt bag is going to defend my
right to freedom of speech or do you
think it's going to call it out and say
why is the Metropolitan Police allowing
this to happen when it's them they say
why is the Metropolitan Police defending
us for the event to happen if I was to
do an event denying the Holocaust they
would say why is the Metropolitan Police
defending them no you're wrong you're
wrong there you go no no you're wrong
yeah I am because you're talking about
denying the Holocaust yes even if you
mention Holocaust in the same line as
the genocide even then like the labor MP
you could be suspended or like the sky
news anchor your job could be and if you
are even objective in your news articles
you are supporting no whoa
no in your face uh Douglas Murray just
two other Clips we let's watch in yeah I
think it's apping because I know one
thing for sure jul the people who hate
the Israelis the people who hate the
Jews the people who we're watching at
the moment marching through Central
London they hate Britain as much as hate
Israel it's just that Britain is first
we're all going to be next so I say
stand up in whichever way you can and if
you're an asist in a theater well you
know do your darn job it's what you're
employed for so interesting so now he's
now he's now he's
equating If U if you don't like
Israel don't like Britain so so this
this is this is unbelievable this is a
joke so this attitude of people can you
imagine coming out and asking by the way
in these marches there are thousands if
not hundred of thousands of non-muslims
so now they are been claimed they are
been accused of anti-semitism now it's
not just the Muslims that hate
apparently Jews now it's them this is an
absolute BS propaganda we as Muslims are
not taught anywhere in our religion that
we hate Jews one of the prophet's wives
was a Jew so to us the people from the
book we can eat from the or used to be a
Jew used to be a Jew but but still we're
talking ethnically not religiously the
point is that that ethnically she was a
Jew we do not have that hatred towards
them and even when it comes to
religiously we have our differences but
nowh in our religion does it tell us to
to be hostile towards them or to even do
oppression towards them you know and the
prophet said anyone that harms AI who
lives under the protection of Muslims
will not smell the fragrance of paradise
so you can see the hypocrisy where he's
trying to equate look we're not going to
fall in this trap let's go back on point
the point is that there is an occupying
Force killing women and children there
are footage being released on a daily
basis has gone to a South African Court
it is no longer a difference of opinion
this is something that's clear as day if
you are ra money for that rest assured
people will come you're talking about
cowards I was going to be there I heard
it was cancelled yeah bro we we we would
be there we would be cowards if we're
not there in fact I'm glad that people
would go there and shut such uh shut
down such events because just like you
have conditions on freedom of speech
that yeah is Free Speech as long as it
doesn't you know uh cause hate it
doesn't as long as it doesn't cause
violence both hate and violence is being
caused by your marches by your people uh
Israel and what they're
doing by consensus of the planet yes you
got America yes you've got Britain okay
a few countries here and there in Europe
but even there's cracks emerging in
Europe as well you've got Spain and
Italy even those are somewhat breaking
ranks as well so on the one hand you
know you're saying yeah freedom of
speech but not freedom of speech if it
hurts the feelings of the the it's not
even Jews because even Jews have a
problem as well Zs and a landmark
victory was today of Professor David
Miller who was sacked from Bristol
University for having anti Zionist views
he won his case today which shows a
presedent has been set that you are
allowed to have anti-zionist views
alhamdulillah we will have it and lastly
ended on this
note dict F be books can written well
you know what not very I'm not very
sensitive but actually I do have
feelings as well my Society has
interesting I am not sensitive as well
but I have feelings soic unbelievable
when you are attacking Islam and our
holy prophet peace be upon him uh the
prophet peace upon him the Quran uh
desecrating it that's freedom of speech
mate stop don't be hurt you know but in
the same breath he says but I have
feelings my country has feelings are you
are you psychologically Disturbed is
there is this cognitive dissonance is
there is there a compartmentalization
what is going on is this left side of
your brain I don't know if you have one
is it paralyzed yeah no what's what's
going on in the same breath you're like
yeah you know I'm not that insensitive
but we have feelings that's the point as
Muslims been saying for the
contradiction what the hell are you on
about yeah that and that's the thing
when people start attacking Islam and
you know even when you're rejecting
Islam as well it leads you to
absurdities and this this guy is a
walking absurdity he's clearly an agent
of Israel pathetic you see him in Tel
Aviv oh there's a bomb coming over me oh
I'm okay I'm brave I don't care calling
his own Countryman coward
they because they don't want support ERS
or because they're like you know what I
don't want to give my life or my
well-being to these people that I have
no connection with and he's trying to
create a connection when there is no
connection Israel has is like a leech
it's been sucking from the UK and the US
and it's high time that the British and
the Americans realize that their
taxpayers are going to these Jokers
frankly that just care about themselves
Christians over there are being spat at
and they're told it's just part of our
culture yes exactly exactly and not only
that the Americans are waking up and
they're saying look I am it's all good
with Israel and z and whatever but
America First the Americans are waking
up and saying why are we sending
billions of dollars and putting this
country first so much so that we have um
legal requirements in certain states
that they have to show show allegiance
to Israel what the hell is going on it's
mad anyway the people are waking up the
whole world is woking up from your
fellow islamists with a
Jihad alaykum
bar